un grand tournoi de handball moins de 18
ans était organisé ce weekend dans les
gymnases d'élancour de morpa et de
Versailles h équipes de la région
Île-de-France ont fait le déplacement
pour participer à la compétition parmi
les favoris on retrouve Boulogne B
encour ponobo et la team 78 l'équipe
locale le niveau est très relevé c'est
que des équipes qui qui V qui jouent le
tableau en National c'est c'est bon ils
ont des bons joueurs il y en a il y en a
ils sont en de formation il y en a ils
sont en équipe de France 4e de la poule
4 du championnat de France l'entraîneur
de la team 78 veut avant tout faire
progresser son groupe pendant ce tournoi
face à de redoutables adversaires à
l'opposé d'accord tu à l'opposé si à
gauche à droite s VI à droite ok pour ça
que tu viens comme il vient là tu viens
là ok ensuite deuxème solution deuxème
solution ça sert à gagner d'expérience
avoir des matchs durs à apprendre à les
gagner à apprendre à rester motivé et
concentré sur les matchs qui sont touche
touche comme on a eu nous on gagne d'un
match d'un but on perd un autre match
d'un but et l'autre en fait il fallait
qu'on gagne de 6 pour gagner et on le
gagne pile de 6 donc c'était comme
c'était un match seré parce qu'il
fallait avoir le bon offensif après une
phase de poule convaincante et un bilan
de deux victoires en tro matchs la team
78 se isse en finale l'équipe va défier
l'ogre créteille l'épouvantail du
tournoi un match compliqué que
l'entraîneur a préparé tactiquement de
tout de suite commencer fort tout de
suite première attaque on l' construit
après on on enchaîne on défend et on
joue monté de balle REP défensif monter
de balle défensif engagement rapide
d'accord les gars fautir mettre du
rythme
d'accord ANDRE taer a porté ses fruits
dans le premier acte la team 78 fait jeu
égal avec créteille l'équipe perd
seulement de deux buts à la mi-temps
mais au retour des vestiaires le rouleau
compresseur crille se met en marche
score final 25-19 on était fatigué on
manquait de rotation et puis au bout
d'un moment c'est l'échec sur les tirs
du gardien adverse qui a qui a donc
remporté le trophée du meilleur gardien
qui nous a fait mal notamment sur des
sur des contre-attaques les trois
premiers matchs ils ont été bons on a
bien joué on est resté
on est resté pareil sur tous les matchs
après celui-là on la première mi-temps
on accroche et la deuxième mi-temps bah
on décroche parce que physiquement c'est
plus compliqué c'est une équipe qui sera
sûrement championne de France cette
année qu'il a été l'année dernière donc
c'est un bon résultat contre cré pendant
ces de jours de compétition la team 78 a
pu montrer sa combativité une qualité
qui sera indispensable le 9 mai pour
venir à bout de trembler en 8e de finale
du championnat de France en attendant
l'équipe peut savourer sa très belle
deuxième place dans ce
[Applaudissements]
tournoi